uh the games have gotten started here we
go right right exactly okay yeah so okay
so we have a Sicilian wait who's white
boy boys right white right okay yeah so
whoever plays this with black as well so
they both say both play that's this
opening so it's gonna be interesting to
see what boy boy has prepared
specifically since he plays this from
the other side too yeah he plays so
usually when you play against someone
who plays your similar opening do you
feel like you get more confident or it
actually kind of trips you out a little
bit um sometimes I would say it trips me
out a little bit Oh what did hutch just
do he just put up his hand like he'd
never seen this before it was a six of a
slip I'm wondering if hutch meant to go
g6 and he he just somehow he confused
the pawns like just in his mind for like
a split second or something well let's
take a listen on hutch maybe he's gonna
tell us what happened
okay he's very focused here I mean even
with that blunder I mean he's he's so
fine you karo told me to push in the
center credit to his coach there this
guy wants to trade down like right away
I'm getting word that his audio is muted
but I can't tell if Kat isn't strong
okay so I know I hear hutches I hear
audio thanks I know they're saying him
or they're thinking they're saying that
I muted because I didn't respond to that
comment okay don't want to true that
here HUD should probably move his queen
out of the center of the board that
would be the best move on to that he
could play like Queen to b6 here yeah
and if he's down is if I can open the
center of the board and he I think he
can just lock it down
we've reached a critical moment well
what do you think of his opening so far
is he slightly worse here he's a little
lower on the clock yeah I mean I think
whites may be a little bit better but
Queen to b6 is a very strong movement
hutch finds it and I think he will find
it I think her okay he goes Bishop e7
instead the only issue black ears in his
LightSquared Bishop can get stuck behind
everyone very easily in this position so
that's a big danger here four four four
four hutch in this position whereas
voyboy spoons are pretty or much more
straight for although now you can play
pawn takes pawn oh there's a big trick
here which is one takes pawn Knight
takes pawn you pawn to e5 which would be
really really nasty because after Knight
takes so pawn takes pawn or okay doesn't
keep time which also by the way is a
good move to right um it's a very
standard move he's grabbing space in the
center here if he takes me five then he
can fix the position of his pawns so a
solid move and he played it pretty
quickly too let's see
boy boy continues with E 5 so he's
keeping the position closed but I really
like C takes d4 now because of Knight
takes d5 he has c5 with tempo and I'm
starting to like his pawn structure he
looks like a good French right at this
point hutch is doing very very well he
can he can probably push his pawn to c5
next move and and I like what hutch is
done
I think hutch is doing extremely well
out of this opening phase it feels like
a position that hutch will also be able
to just make natural looking moves and
finish his development and he really
likes it to bishops which shows a very
deep positional understanding and a deep
love of these like kind of very
technical middle games so from from
hutch aside I think that he's got a
great position here two bishops just
really really nice right one challenge
for him though will be where is he
to put his night on g8 because can't go
to f6 age six looks a little bit scary
because he has to be willing to open up
his King side and double up his pawns
and the knight obviously can't go to e7
because the bishop is there so even
though he has a nice position his
development isn't that straightforward
correct yeah so I mean that's the only
drawback here but again I don't like
this position for voyboy
I really think that the only thing he
has here is that black cannot easily
develop that night and get the King out
of the center of the board but the two
bishops once the diagonal is open up
will be really really powerful like this
should be seven and the idea of pawn to
d4 and I think that that it's really
really a really nice position proach to
have at this point the game yeah I I
don't disagree there they're also very
similar in the the time situation so if
you take that into account it seems like
hutch is the one who has played the
opening better definitely yeah but let's
listen also to what boi boi is thinking
I mean obviously both sides still have
chances here switching to his stream now
it's just very focused
it's good because he's thinking on on
hutchins move and that's something you
should always be doing to try to save as
much time as you can especially in these
short time formats right agreed yeah so
so yeah at this point I think I mean
it's important that Hutch makes some of
the moves relatively quickly like here
bringing the bishop of pushing banner
feels very somatic but it's not it's not
so easy to spot this especially when
there's a lot of pressure here but I do
it I do expect hutch to find something
along its lines but that being said boy
boy is so quiet right now he's like he's
just not talking he's too deep in
thought um I mean his development I
think seems a little bit easier actually
because he can castle very soon he can
take his knight out to c3 Oh Queen b6 is
a nice tricky move yeah it's a very very
nice move here by uh so he's gonna have
to protect me too he can push the C pawn
and defend it with his queen that's one
option yes here you also pushed the beep
on I guess with an idea c4 but it
doesn't make any his dark squares a
little bit I think I would prefer
probably was a more thematic move that
he thought he should have played but at
this point in time I think I think it's
still very unclear it's still it's still
very very unclear for for both sides the
the game I think will be decided
probably in the next 10 moves so maybe
not the actual result but basically who
gets the advantage and who is gonna be
clearly ahead and in the driver's seat I
really like this Bishop d8 moved by
hutch it's not the best move objectively
but it's a very classy move just to
bring the knight into the game get your
King out of the center and I think hutch
is in very good shape right now if he
finds the correct way of developing this
light square Bishop with Bishop e7 and
upon d4 at the right moment right he's
fixing all of the positional problems we
talked about earlier with the awkward
development of his knight
so if he was able to find that I I'm not
gonna be surprised when he finds a move
like Bishop e7 and he starts activating
his rook into the middle game as well
right correct yeah so I mean at this
point I think I don't know I I think I
think it's anyone's game I just as much
as I can do like high level commentary
I'm trying to keep it at a certain
certain level and what when I think
about the position that both players
have I don't think the plans are obvious
but I do think blacks plan is more
obvious than White's plan so that's the
main reason I think at this point in
time cut should be better should be
better but I it's hard okay well at a
certain level yes mm-hmm
so your ear right the the time situation
is so close it's complicated
for both sides here in terms of trying
to find straightforward plans there's
still a couple moose I like rook d1
because he's improving the position of
his rook at some point voyboy can also
improve the position of his knight on b1
I think it's gonna become even more
difficult once they've finished their
full development here so she you know
hutch also castles and takes on his
bishops yeah right agreed um so so yeah
I think I mean again the thing is if
you're playing the white pieces what you
objectively want to do is put upon on c4
and then bring the knight out behind it
but I think that's way too deep of a
concept and it's a very hard concept to
understand because the reasoning behind
doing that is that you basically try and
try to close both the bishops out of the
game um so white is doing okay but the
the ideas feel really they felt really
hard to find to me at least when I just
think about this that's fair
let's take a listen on hutch and see if
we can get in me insight into his plan
here I like that move that's a good move
by him very aggressive
all right so yes so quiet we're not used
to seeing this right yeah I mean I think
it shows you how serious the players are
now it's just like they're so quiet
they're just so focused at what's going
on it's like they're every every bit of
energy they have they're just using it
to concentrate focus does he sack no and
it's good that he played h6 instead of
taking which I don't have a boy boys
take some of this pressure off still
both players so close on the clock I
don't think we've ever seen players this
close just throughout the game in terms
of their time situation right yeah so I
mean at this point and then my games
like not turn whoa what I'm saying about
my game right now
what is she for that's crazy powerful
powerful move it's probably not a bad
move but it feels really insane to go
all in for the attack here but this is
very tricky here for both sides right I
mean so if boy boy thought that his
position was worse but I feel like it's
hard to tell how much worse your
position is at this stage because it's
still very complicated so it doesn't
seem like it made sense for him to go
for some kind of desperado or or
last-ditch attempt and if you didn't
calculate it all the way through then
this might very well lead to his
unwinding correct yeah so I mean I like
the concept I think it's very tricky for
both players here I think black is
probably winning if you take the bishop
with the pawn here but it's very hard to
do this like pawn takes knight upon
takes bishop pawn takes knight and then
pawn to g4 is probably winning for black
but very very hard to UM calculate this
correctly with with the amount of time
on the clock
true so so high hutch is just here
calculating he's looking at both of
those captures from what I see on his
board
well what else does he have to consider
here because when you're sitting on this
position you just try to come up with
some options right so he probably sees
his knight is under attack he can
technically consider moving it but then
his pawn on h6 looks very vulnerable
H takes g5 is certainly the number one
variation yes I calculate so I guess
it's good that he's taking his time here
that's probably what he's doing right
and I think it's important because if
you move the night backwards and white
kind of then white can Wow what is that
sexist what a move
wow this is crazy um let's see okay so
now I think f6 is actually a very good
move but I don't think hutch sees
everything behind I think it's actually
a very good move but I don't think that
it's I'm sure that he doesn't see the
whole idea behind it now the thing here
is is he should take the bishop I think
again he has to take the bishop here
it's imperative or else wait doesn't he
just down a piece yeah because he did he
did although although he's gonna end up
getting rook takes Knight and now he's
the one attacking White's
open King so this is actually gonna be
very interesting it definitely is gonna
be interesting but he did miss the key
there of making sure that he took a
piece back because if his attack doesn't
pan out now he's just down material but
you're right it's a very scary attack
this is brilliant by hutch it's not like
he intended this but this is brilliant
because unintentionally brilliant yeah
because the thing is you can move the
bishop to b7 it and swing your other
recover and the white King is completely
open I think he's actually completely
winning here well it's it's gonna be
brilliant if he sees it he has to have
the follow-up it reminds me of when you
know students would find fantastic
tactics well they'd find the first move
without the full plan and that obvious I
mean if he if he saw this I I will be
very seriously impressed he saw his
whole line through on and I think we'll
know right away if he did because his
next couple of moves should be really
straightforward like Bishop could be
seven and swing the work to update and
this is where I want to see how whether
he really saw the idea or not he saw the
idea his next like two or three move
should be boom boom boom
well this is another great moment to
listen on his stream I want to see if
this is what he's going for he's
hovering over b7 Wow
okay he played Bishop e7 Hikaru prepare
to be impressed
chat yeah he deserves he deserves your
your excitement right now and he's gonna
play rook f8 wow this is this is this is
masterful this is I mean I don't know
what the evaluation is objectively but I
think there's gonna be very hard boy
weight correctly king is gonna be under
a lot of pressure immediately here could
be worse could be worse pawn here
I think hutch is still a little bit
worried by by his position here yeah I
mean I don't know D 5 D for D for as
good FIV 4 is good all the pot even c4 I
think it's good here too but uh-oh Oh
deep oh boy oh boy oh boy
uh-oh and the reason this is really
scary so now now the Ignite is attacked
three times if the knight ever moves
then the pawn on f2 is hanging um I mean
she he can bring his Queen in on the
attack as well
maybe you would have been better to do
that after getting rid of the night
Queen c6 is a great move though all
moves lead to Rome here for hutch but
Queen c6 is really good because now the
sacrifice becomes very obvious although
maybe I can play Brooke g1 here and
create some mating threats with a queen
g6 idea down the road
yeah that would be some good counterplay
you might as well try to go for it
at this stage hutch is so quiet he's so
focused this is this is a yeah [__]
three masters was actually winning for
sure with with fish take them moving the
Queen but this also I mean boy boy
veteran boy really likes to be the guy
attacking and so here he's having to
defend which I think makes us really
really obviously in trouble mom and I
think he's much stronger attacking the
defending when he's talking him four
times he's defending it if he moves
that's a devastating check but I think
I'm winning
sure I've missed something right now bow
ties and Hikaru like no no no boat
doesn't he car proud of you huh chief
late incredibly I got him thinking this
has been really incredible I'm not gonna
lie like I don't think Hutch understood
the strength of the idea when he went
into it but this is but the way that
he's played this game after that pawn to
g4 is is is great it's way beyond 1,400
for sure so yeah well you put his rating
performance out for this game I mean I
don't know if you can say it's the
performance but like the idea that he
saw is what's one really matters and and
the fact that he understood that he
could actually give this piece and
activate the bishop this has been more
or less a model game yes a couple assets
haven't been the absolute best move so
boy boy has some shots at getting some
counter play here but overall this a
model game is something that certainly I
would I would be showing to young
children who were trying to learn the
game of shots this hutch has played a
model game so far oh well that's amazing
and I mean as you mentioned so rook f1
boy boy is trying to defend that f2
square in the future he has a really
straightforward idea now of just taking
the night which he goes for it makes
sense because he will be able to get two
nights for for just a rook but on top of
that he still has his attack which is
even more important right I mean at the
same time however voyboy might be able
to escape with his King towards the
center of the board but this is looking
very tough very very difficult sort of
position okay now he blunders with Queen
g6 he should have taken the rook because
now hutch can move the rook back and
just move the rook back to f6 and attack
the Queen and then he's gonna be ahead
by some or I guess it's even know he's
ahead by one pawn and the white king is
completely open um so yeah hutch is
playing a great game um and this is what
I think we were expecting to see how to
putt yesterday a little bit of a hiccup
but he's he's playing some fantastic
chess right now
and boy boy is doing his best to defend
here let's listen on his stream and see
what his hopes are he's under 2 minutes
on the clock now still very focused he's
trying to do his
to defend in just such a difficult
position yeah he's not even talking he's
not saying a single word he's just
putting you know his entire brain usage
into this game as he should because
there's still chances to say that his
King might get an escape square if hutch
doesn't play it accurately and he plays
maybe too slowly let's say it takes Rick
takes right it takes and what do you
think boy boys best chance to try to
survive this game would be um if he can
get in his other work to e1 and get his
King manually Castle to the other side
of the board he'll have a shot but he
needs Rick you want to swing the King
behind it that's the only way that I
think he can maybe get chances to win
I'm very concerned I mean if hutch plays
pawn to e5 here I don't like this move
however Queen to d5 oh wait no hutch is
playing for Queen h5 check oh very mean
so now I wanted to go rook e1 but then
if I go rook e1 you have Queen to h5
check and and the King can't escape
right well I mean I guess he has to go
for for f3 but then as soon as the King
moves to d1 the f3 pawn would hang okay
now clutch finds Queen h5 I think it's
game over basically here c4 is it tribe
really the only idea he had was to
manually castle the king I mean [__]
seize Queen h5 again on the next turn I
think it's it's pretty much game over
for voyboy
after Queen takes c3 yes yes I mean it's
probably winning no matter what black
does but it's probably the cleanest
quickest way to win the game here for
for hutch and I think as long as hutch
makes these moves relatively quickly and
doesn't let the time even out here he's
gonna win and I mean he made a move like
Queen d5 which wouldn't have had a lot
of other ideas I was gonna say that's
why I expect you to Queen h5 but Queen
g2 I guess also makes sense he's putting
pressure on f2 he's attacking it three
times
it's defended twice so boy boy has to
play something like Queen e3 bringing in
another defend
but even that at that stage I feel like
he can try to bring his bishop in with a
five bishop a six it's just too many
pieces on the white king right but white
can play Queen g3 here which is which is
also a good move to try and stay in the
game it's probably losing but okay so he
takes the pawn and I feel like hutch
just has to find a couple of good moves
here and he'll be in he should win the
game yeah and it's not it's not easy
though it's not easy at all okay but if
he does find queen g4 we were waiting
for this move f3 does make sense
although he can just take it because
it's attacked four times I'm just gonna
draw the arrows and it's only defended
three times so yeah really really tough
tough position but incredible game by
hutch and I think it all came down to as
soon as voyboy made that mistake with h4
and now Bishop e2 would would win the
game mm-hmm well hutch see it or not I
mean he's he's seen so many good moves
so far
rookie rookie 8 is probably more
intuitive although the follow up is
harder because now the King is almost
getting to safety right no the king is
has gotten to safety basically so now I
mean I think hutch still should win the
game due to the time situation but say
like a move like pawn to e5 here which i
think is very good is very hard move to
play yeah now it's now I mean it's still
winning but it's it's not gonna be easy
here for for hutch to win yeah the the
reason why he 5 you mentioned is because
then you could bring the rook to c8 it
would be protected by the Queen he goes
for a similar idea with rook f8 where he
is preparing c8 here mm-hmm
okay boy boy takes okay so now yeah a
knight c4 was actually I wonder if white
could have tried to survive now probably
Queen f6 check it would be winning and
it's interesting because if you look at
the the piece count hutch is only up
upon so like say in a crazy situation he
trades off all the pieces oh it does
have some drawstring he's very tricky
here this I don't like at all what does
this move this is what I was talking
about this is gonna give voivode wrong
chances oh wow this is gonna why doesn't
he take it yeah there's gonna be very
choppy now so probably queen 85 checking
rook d2 is winning here well hutch see
it is a big question well let's listen
on his stream and see if he's finding
these moves
okay sorry he's just so quiet well you
can continue explaining on top then yeah
this is gonna be very I mean I don't
even know who's gonna win this game at
this point I think hutch should win if
he can exchange the Queen's because he's
gonna have his pawns going forward now
and his rook will be very aggressive
whereas in the other position he would
have had to use his work as a defender
here it's gonna be an attacker to try
and take the white pawns oh no oh no oh
dad his name is not Alexandre okay he
karo
oh man that is a rough finish for voyboy
and he had the thing is he had chances
to to recover I'm just gonna go back to
that one point where it just Steven oh
man that's so brutal cuz like he almost
came all the way back and he actually
probably was not even losing if he
traded the Queen's here and moved the
King up it's a really really really
brutal game to lose after he came all
the way back from from from a completely
losing position so very very rough but I
think now everybody kind of has lost the
game so we're gonna see how strong boys
mental is here and whether he can
recover because this is uh this is gonna
be tough since he has not lost a game
yet right except for that that game with
Iran but we won't count that one so
boy boy is now going to have the black
pieces um hutch is gonna have the white
pieces it is 1 0 and hutches favor and
he was just telling a shot don't freak
out yet it's not over and that's
absolutely the right mindset to have you
don't want to get too confident or too
comfortable you got to take every game
as seriously as the first one right
definitely true yeah all right so do you
think he should tweak his strategy at
all he just I was done you know we
haven't really asked at the lower
ratings but they're at the stage where
he can try to go for something more
solid yeah I mean I think I think
actually that's one thing that plays to
hutches favor is that he is one of these
guys who plays addy for the pawn push in
front of the Queen to start the game eat
ends have a very kind of classical and
elegant opening style so I think that's
definitely a big plus for him but again
the game but again the match is uh I
mean the match is still it's still only
one game and you never know how they're
gonna respond to the pressure so um
there's some funny comments in the chest
comm chat saying botas gambit declined
his best but botas can't accept his a
blunder right I also know someone else
said the boy boy's mental is much
stronger considering they played LCS
which I think in a way is true boy boy
certainly has has had more competitive
as it was a former professional league
player he's had more like competitive
experience even if it's not in chess but
sort of facing a lot of adversity so I
think as mental should be pretty good
here he should be pretty strong it's
important that he they stays focused and
tries to find the best moves well the
games are off and we have what looks
like a Kings Indian from from voyboy I
didn't even know he played this against
you for it so it's a hard opening to
play very early on I think because you
end up having your dark-squared bishop
blocked and you can get a nice kind of a
King side attack but you're often down
so much space really on for pawn attack
my gosh as soon as I as soon as I start
talking really start saying really good
things about about hutches openings
he decides that you know he wants to
play the most aggressive
system against the Kings Indian defense
which is this four pawns attack you put
the four pawns in the center I do not
like this at all considering the
situation where he's ahead 1-0 on there
sir no things that I think are just it's
just very very it's it's it's very
aggressive and you try to win the game
you try to take the center and like put
a chokehold on your opponent um but
again your center pawns are very exposed
they're very advanced so your opponent
can attack them really easily so I mean
if hutch knows this very well I think
he'll be fine but I think it's a very
very dangerous opening choice to play in
a game where you just need to be very
solid and stable because this this is
gonna lend itself to a lot of tactics a
very very aggressive approach from both
players and I think anything can happen
although he's so five which is not the
correct move I don't yeah I was gonna
say that they both played theory until
here I was impressed with voyboy finding
six but II five is the first deviation
and it goes to show what you were just
saying he might not know this line that
well and if that's the case it's a very
risky choice when he has the white
pieces and he just needs a draw right so
I mean I feel like I've looked I looked
at this line maybe about like 17 years
ago maybe ish okay
about 13 I think I was studying this for
pawns with my stepfather and we looked
at a line here which I think goes Knight
g4 um it's like Knight g4 and I think
it's Bishop g5 Queen b6 I think it is
it's Bishop she fought or maybe it's
Bishop f4 what's the order I'm trying to
remember how its line goes oh no it's
slightly different as a lot how can you
not remember something from from 17
years ago what is such doing he's
throwing this game what is he doing why
is he playing like this this is not how
you play the four pawns yeah he's just
losing the opening Knight takes Knight
and Queen h4 check and it's finished
it's a completely finished game over oh
I don't know why he'd pick this opening
let's let's listen in on him maybe he
has something to say let's go he's just
quiet
it he's as quiet as I am after that I
don't know what to say hey I have a
check that I need to concern myself with
yeah I mean the problem here is that
Beasley his center has completely
collapsed and after black takes the pawn
and moves his rook to over one square
everything is gonna collapse almost
instantly for white right and and that's
the main theme in the for pawn and the
fact that voyboy knew the e6 idea makes
me think that he's for sure gonna know
the idea of trying to open up the center
get your work on the open file before
your opponent can castle here No yeah
take this do I take with the partner do
I take this rook to e8 or pawn takes
pawn I mean if I take with the planet I
think he will win this you know hammers
him a little bit easily but yes to find
it first and there's no guarantee that
he will take with a knight I'm ready to
like hop into an attack if I need to I
made this move here because if like so
take Queen and then check I can come
down here oh no I mean the thing is that
the whites position is so exposed here
the black has time at least to take it
slower but it's not the move that
bothers me it's that maybe he didn't see
the idea and that's a bigger problem if
he doesn't go for it at any point he
does have to take d5 at some point I
guess so the thing is he can still put
the bishop on b7 as well - that's a
satiric it's not the most precise attack
but he is ahead by one pond so I think
boy boy is in good shape but he just
guys stay very calm and really try not
to try not to to panic at any point
because again he's behind one zero but
this is this is a slow game and he's got
a lot of time here to work it out so I
think boy boy just needs to be confident
stay focused and and good things should
happen
okay well um now it's this hutch this
turn to play here is there anything he
can try to do I mean he wants to castle
as quickly as possible so he does want
to take his Bishop out at some point do
you think he should get rid of the
knight on e5 first I know he should
definitely move the Bishop to e2 cuz
then he can capture with the bishop and
then attack the rook all the way down
that long diagonal potentially so um see
does go push me to okay so he's going
for it
um right so now it's very important that
a boy boy goes Bishop to d7 and the
thing is so the Queen wants to hop on on
h4 he can also take the knight Bishop
takes and move the Queen h4
if he comes Bishop f1 is queen takes e4
to risky or does that look like a good
line for voyboy here sorry which one
so Knight takes of three Bishop takes of
three and Queen h4 I mean maybe it's
okay but why can go Bishop to f2 and
then when you capture the pawn on c4
White takes the pawn on e6 with the
discovery on the rook on AE so I think
it's probably okay for black but he gets
very complicated and then anything can
happen right it's it's a it's a very
messy position but it's also exciting
because then White's king is still in
the center of the board but totally you
know he'd uh boy doesn't want to risk
losing here so she he shouldn't go for
that kind of crazy line well no he
actually should in a way well I mean he
should do stuff that leads to where he
can win the game cuz winning or losing
is fine just make sure that he has
chances to win no matter what so even if
he does something that's maybe a blunder
objectively it's still a good choice
because the draw gets and nothing he has
to win this game there's only one result
that works for him I mean while that's
true he can go for pushing for a win in
in variations that make him less likely
to lose as well because he still has a
really good chance no no
oh that's that's really really rough oh
my gosh she just resigned Hikaru
we got a resignation it's going to the
tiebreak Wow all right you know one
thing I've noticed that I think is kind
of interesting these matches maybe every
single match works like their opponent
against that's kind of just that
something has gone wrong in that second
game like whether it's like the
disbelief at winning that first game or
it's just the overall pressure it feels
like something has always gone wrong in
that second game so like for example you
look at xqc his second game really went
wrong early you look at NIM against
hutch after a brilliant first game
second game went wrong slicker another
example won a game in the second game he
kind of tilted as well so I think maybe
it's just some of the players because
they don't expect to win when they get
that first win they breathe a sigh of
relief and they kind of kick back and
relax a little bit too much and and then
they lose that second game and then you
end up with the with blitz game where
anything really can happen and but
they're the reason that I'm surprised to
have seen this is because we listened in
on hutches stream and he was saying it's
not over yet I still have to focus so it
seemed like he had the right mindset but
then the opening he played with and the
speed and the blenders just did not live
up to what his words were saying right
right yeah I mean I thought the opening
choice was just way too aggressive by
hutch in a game where he where he should
be more stable and more solid mind you
the Kings Indian defense is not an
opening you see very much at this level
but nonetheless it felt too aggressive
it felt sort of out of out of sync with
what his style normally is and and the
fact that boy boy knew how to attack the
center at the very start played a very
critical role in him going wrong and not
finding the right continuations well the
next game is gonna start in the next
three minutes or so we are gonna have
the tiebreaks it's gonna be 3o time
control boy boy is going to have the
white pieces versus hutch who's gonna
have the black pieces because boy boy
has been higher in the standings so far
so this is gonna be exciting the second
tie break of the day we've honestly just
been in for a really exciting finale
all right well voyboy versus hutch we've
talked about how close this is in in
three Oh which one of them do you think
has the edge um I think it's pretty
close I would say that uh that I think
Boyd Boyd has the advantage he seems to
be a little bit sharper tactically so I
think that boy boys should be the
favorite but it's gonna be a very close
match I don't think it I don't think
it's I I think it's a matter of who
keeps who controls their nerves at the
very start of the game for the first 10
to 15 moves and then then when they get
the time advantage not not letting it
slip away so it's whoever finds the best
moves in the quickest amount of time at
this point because both players have
shown that they're very capable of
finding good moves and um it's gonna
just gonna be a lot of fun to see what
about psychological factors do you think
it's gonna be more difficult for hutch
because he's just coming out of a very
quick loss um I don't think it will make
that big of a difference because
certainly when these guys are playing I
don't think you're in a situation where
we're we're you know necessarily that
you're as good as your opponent or
you're better you're worse you never
really have this great idea whereas for
example if I play a game I'm usually
playing someone in my rating range where
I literally feel like when you get that
advantage you you don't want it let it
let it slip away so in this sort of
situation I don't think it matters as
much per se and I think the fact that
hutch lost game eat quickly and with
just being in blender is much better
than let's say getting outplayed and
ending up in a really bad position I
mean this yeah I agree with that and I
just want to take it back for a second
because this has been a super exciting
tournament I'm honestly really happy
that chess calm and twitch put it
together and chat if you guys are
watching and you haven't followed the
chess calm account yet don't spam know
in the chat okay just just go and hit
that follow button and on that note
we're we're also gonna take a listen on
voyboy stream not this chat you guys are
so predictable no it's a poison jamming
no go on it back same three finals Tyriq
alright ready
and the game has started here we go here
we go oh no they just move so quickly
and what we saw last time is they moved
too fast between xqc and Ludwig and
mistakes were made
exactly yeah so okay so normal opening
here open Sicilian Bishop c5 played by
uh by hutch a little bit of a rare move
I'm 95 good move by boy boy okay okay
right yeah so okay so we're back okay
all right so in this position probably
hutch has to find a way to activate this
LightSquared Bishop probably playing
pawn to b5 and Bishop to d7 would be the
best way to play this but again it feels
very much in void void style here just
pushing the pawn on the Kings side like
f4 f5 with the SH beat six ideas just a
very very very good position for boy boy
I think he's doing well okay well he's
yeah like you mentioned he's also up on
the time umm Bishop f4 I don't like
because he was almost supposed to give
away his Bishop pair which is one of the
advantages in his position but I do like
the speed with which he's playing yeah I
think at this point I think it's at this
point boy boy has gotten a position that
looks very natural um whereas I think
for hutch it's a lot harder to play this
position
oh no queenie for attacking the rook and
checkmate he just blundered it's over
uh-oh if he soars it okay goes rookie
three okay so we're still on the edge of
our seat here okay so okay so Queen g3 I
feel like it's gonna be very easy though
again for VOIPo to play he can push the
pawn to h4 he can bring the rook and all
of white's moves here fold very very
natural whereas hutches moves don't feel
natural at all so now I would okay
Bishop e4 I guess is okay I don't love
it the main point being that at some
point black is gonna push the F pawn to
f5 and then trade the trade the pieces
but this now takes 94 should be crushing
for white or h4 h5 also is very very
good yeah I mean I I generally agree
with it with the attack ideas it just
feels like
she's been slowly giving the advantage
back wrong right yeah let's listen in on
hutch see what yes stay here or what
he's just thinking and we can just
continue our analysis hmm oh wow this is
really intimidating age can you just
continue with age for here now you find
this hanging actually has to be a little
bit careful maybe he has to bring the
rook back to e3 Queen c7 is an excellent
move here and now he should play pawn to
f5 if he plays pawn to f5 he's gonna be
doing very very well I think although he
has one minute on the clock
oh no oh no he blundered the fork
boy boy blundered but boy boys up 30
seconds on the clock it could still be
anybody's game here
I mean hutch is gonna really have to
play faster right h6 is a good move now
whoa this is gonna be close oh okay so
hutch can take this pawn he doesn't okay
now rook d6 okay trades okay I don't
like this trade though I don't like this
trade I like the fact that he's playing
fast so I think that's almost more
important he has to try to get boy boy
the same amount of time on his clock
here cuz 40 seconds is terrifying okay
so it's gotta go okay you gotta go boy
boy needs to move fast he's losing on
the board so he needs to move quicker
oh man hutch has got to go he's got to
go he's got 30 seconds you gotta go you
gotta go fun hutch no increment here oh
no he's taking away too long you gotta
go you gotta go you gotta go
well that's what everyone wanted to see
anyway the close time scrambled before I
hope he pre moves show us you have your
pre moves on hutch oh why didn't he
bring move that makes me nervous but
he's about to take c2 23 seconds oke
garu oh my gosh not a move make a Queen
move make it Shaq
okay okay 20 seconds so here we go work
c2 okay
is he gonna sack the rook for the night
he should sack the rook for the night
fifteen seconds yeah you can at least
get a draw then if you Trey
off all of his pawns with 14 seconds you
want to first get the draw chances in
there make sure you push the pawn push
the pawn eight seconds okay just leave
the knight on the board and take the two
pawns get a draw take a pawn G for three
seconds oh my gosh take take the pawn
and the winner he came in even in a
worse position he was faster in the
horrea won he won by the dirty flag but
that is something that you always have
to take into account he was playing
faster and you know but oh my gosh that
was a close game
if hutch would have only gotten rid of
the two pawns he would have at least
gotten a draw here right yeah he should
have taken the pawn on g3 rather than
exchange in the work for the night just
unfortunate mental slip at the end there
but someone had to win the game and
envoy boy certainly played very well so
he did he did he did deserve to win the
event yeah and this was the close game
the tiebreaker that everyone was waiting
for so I mean a huge shout out to both
hutch and voyboy for putting their all
out there and making it exciting for the
fans mm-hmm well chat hang around
because we have one more final today the
consolation bracket winner will also be
determined the game between the Ludwig
and moist critical we already have the
champion now of the champion bracket so
that is a boy boy with hutch in second
but there will be one more decisive
results today
mm-hm so I think you know overall I was
still really really impressed with both
of these two players yeah I think I
think they definitely showed they belong
to the final and I'm some fortunate
somebody had to win and somebody had to
lose I'm still very bad for hutch cuz he
he probably he should have won that
final game especially but again the the
clock is a part of the game in blitz
chess and I'm he was a little bit too
slow at some of the critical moments so
therefore I mean I certainly think boy
boy he found the right lose at the end
and he thought a way to win the game we
are back we are joined by hutch and
voyboy
let me start off by congratulating you
boy boy congratulations you are the
pogchamp champion Congrats dude thank
you a high flame and those that was some
of the hardest ever did ya know that
first game was crazy man I know you had
me sweaty I was on the roofs I was like
shaking do such a good attack that's
crazy yeah he card you want to comment
on hutches performance in the first game
I knew you were just so impressed yeah I
was actually one question I had
specifically was with that sacrifice of
the night intentional or not when you
played this on push to f6 absolutely not
is a brilliant idea like it was it was a
really brilliant idea and you followed
it up with all the correct moves so it
just seemed like something that you had
seen from from far away because it
really it really was masterful the way
you attacked towards white King well I
watched a bunch of chess Network
commentating on Bobby Fischer games last
night so maybe some osmosis give now I
think it was accidental brilliance it
was just great and actually they
completely turned it around so it looked
like you were in a lot of trouble in
that game and then and then all your
moves were great it took me a minute to
like process that I had a winning
position because I was the piece down
and then I just kept on staring at the
boredom and it just occurred to me I'm
like I think he's losing this game if I
play correctly here yeah I was like that
that mean the guy who's like he's all
happy and then he like realizes
something and he's like wait what I was
like oh nice I got up I'm up a piece
like this is perfect and I was like wait
I really sacked like my whole King
structure for this oh yeah he's
attacking me oh god I gotta run Oh
what's happening that's kind of how I
went down in that second game so hutch
he car and I were a little bit surprised
that you chose to go for the four pawn
attack there it seemed really aggressive
and one of those more unsound opening
choices can tell us more about that
decision you know I knew that it was a
bad idea to do that but it's kind of a
meme on my on my channel that I always
push the pawn when they let me
if I didn't do that they would give me
they would give me crap for it so as
soon as I dropped the pot I was like
well I'm screwed now well you are you're
a content creator first so so that
doesn't make a lot of sense but that
final game was so exciting oh my gosh I
mean hutch you had the advantage but you
were down on the clock boy boy you're
playing really quickly a couple
inaccuracies but you took the lead and
you know at the end there it could have
been anybody's game I don't know boy boy
I mean how are you feeling when you saw
you're finally able to fly him
well I mean the whole time I wasn't
really looking for like the best move I
was just trying to play like semi
accurately and try to put pressure on
him like go for the Kings I attack to
make to make hutch like have to think
about how to defend against like my
pieces coming in stuff so I think I I
kind of knew I was building up an
advantage on the clock and I I kind of
like you know missed the knife Fork and
I think I might've missed like a winning
play earlier too but I was just pretty
confident as long as I you know just
kept playing like you know pretty good
chess not not GM chess just pretty good
chess I could I could win that way so
you know it was really close it was it
was an intense last game but you know
I'm happy I came out on top early
yeah hutch I mean you also played that
game incredibly and at some point in the
endgame we were thinking that you could
have tried to just make sure you get the
two pawns off the board so you'd at
least have a draw was that a plan you
thought of at all no like not in the
time it's the time pressure like I know
about doing that but it just didn't
occur to me just because boy boy boy
such a strong a blitz player and he
knows how to he knows how to like you're
saying make the semi accurate moves that
I have to address like he kept on
checking me and at the end there you
know just taking like a couple seconds
off but those couple seconds like add up
when you do that over and over again and
by the time I looked at my clock I was
like man if I had like 10 seconds I
could for sure made him and couldn't do
it know that that's very well put it is
so hard to get used to these slower time
controls but hutch I saw that really
wholesome tweet you put out about how
you feel chess has been improving you as
a person can you talk a little bit more
about that yeah I talked about it a bit
before but I just I think there's so
much value to chance that go
beyond the blurred problem solving
creativity pattern recognition these are
all characteristics and qualities that
you can take with you off the board and
then also just the confidence to because
when you're starting out at chess you're
400-500 rate of play or whatever it's
not too difficult to grind and study and
then see like an incredible improvement
really fast and that can be really good
for your self-esteem too especially with
kids like I think like the earlier you
introduce chess to kids the better off
they're gonna be I think on average they
get better grades so I mean I can't I
think I think it's a really wonderful
thing that this tournament brought
attention to the game and potentially
got you know thousands of people
interested I think that's great yeah and
speaking of starting chess off young we
know voyboy did and boy boy obviously
you know you're a competitive
competitive league player what was it
like being in such a serious chess
environment yeah I was like I don't
watch that too like my dad taught me how
to play chess when I was like a little
kid and I loved it it was the first time
like you know I actually got to out play
like these old men like my uncles and
like you know ons and like cousins and
stuff I would just be like you know 7
years old and it's like playing chess
with my dad and like trying to beat him
and then eventually I beat him and I
started playing my family and you know
um I I love tres as a kid obviously that
does help me to be a better chess player
now I haven't played in like so I
basically quit playing when I was like
10 or something but you know I
definitely think like what I dress is
super true I think it helped me you know
do better in school like have a better
strategic mind like you know just
thinking about problem solving skills
and logic and stuff like that and I
think even like what you feel what you
said like being a professional you
legends player like I remember when I
was like 16 years old and like playing
League and like playing my first
tournaments like I was trying to like
think how can I break League down from
like a chess oh how can I break like
laning phase like how can I like you
know gain tempo and like building
abandoned stuff and I think those are
things that actually helped me like be
really good at League early on before a
lot of people were thinking like such a
strategic way and yeah it was it was it
was an awesome experience so I went off
on like a rant ended but it was an
awesome experience to compete in chess
clock chance you know hutch is super
super good I think we're both you know
deserved winners of all this but I'm
that I barely came out on top and yeah
just thanks for thanks to chest calm and
all the fans and everyone all the GM's
all the people who helped coach us and
and made this event possible and yeah
it's been nothing but fun nothing but
love it's been super awesome to to get
back into the chess again and kind of
reignite a passion that was basically
dormant since I was a kid and so the
thing about Connect you are a mind
taking too much time you finish you
should finish this thought it's okay
okay I was I say well hutch says like
you can like improve a lot in like a
short period of time like if you look at
like you know two weeks ago I don't know
maybe I was like 12 maybe 1,300
something I died and then I played like
non-stop chest four last two weeks and
now I'm like close to like 15 1600
whatever so if you look at that like
improvement like 300 you know in like
two weeks if I play for another two
weeks
a 1,900 another two weeks you know 2200
2528 Hikaru I'm all I'm saying next
World Championships I'm a you're gonna
be seeing this peak being across the
board I'm coming for your spot kiddo
it's you you you and boss walks both you
both you both literally said that exact
same thing wait he said that - I don't
like ya 400 points every week same thing
but anyway ya know it's it's it's great
though and again congrats to both of you
guys I think you both played
phenomenally well I mean it's
unfortunate there had to be a winner and
a loser but certainly like to hutch I
mean you've been around so long you've
been you've been playing chess I think
on twitch for I mean it was like five
six years ago at least and I'm not sure
if you saw us but one of the other
competitors is in the other final Ludwig
he said that you actually inspired him
he saw you playing chess many years ago
so just thank you
thanks for everything you've done for
her chess and then for the community
yeah yeah yeah I tried to get into
Ludwig Ludwig's game last night and
teach him how to mate with a king and a
queen but I couldn't get it done but
like one one more thing about chess that
I do want to say like real quick I know
we got a wrap-up but um just what like a
couple good things about the game is
that it forces you to confront your own
mistakes and it forces you to consider
your opponent's moves and those are also
two like really valuable skills that you
can apply in so many different areas of
your life so I mean I there's just so
many different ways that that chess can
help you out I think
well hutch boy boy thank you guys so
much
boy boy congratulation for the
championship title and hutch
congratulations for runner up and I'm
looking forward to watching you both get
that you know 300 point a low gain week
after week thank you guys for doing such
a good job commentating you guys have
done a really good job of making it
funny and interesting and accessible so
good good for you guys well appreciate
it very much
and take care of both of you all right
bye thank you
[Music]